(claps)
♪ Single, single, we are single ♪
♪ How single are you ♪
♪ Very single ♪
(bright music)
(laughing)
- It makes me laugh but also
cry inside a little bit.
- It also hurts your heart.
- I know.
- I am plagued with the
on-again, off-again.
- I'm very single right now.
I'm actually dating a lot,
I love to meet new people.
- It's fun being friends with Curly
just for the gossip or the
chisme 'cause it's like,
Oh my god I was with this guy
yesterday and he said this.
And I'm like, what?
And then, Oh my God,
you remember that guy?
Which guy?
Oh no, the other guy,
the one that I was telling
you about Wednesday.
- I am in a committed,
monogamous relationship.
It's almost gonna be two years now.
We live together.
We have two cats.
It's very serious, I guess.
- Everything you said
was an anxiety attack.
- What?
- That was scary, oh man, the cats?
I'm just allowing toothbrushes.
- I am so single right
now, it is not even funny.
- I think it's very similar
to why I think I'm single.
I think that we're picky and
we're insecure all together
so it's like Oh no, I'm too,
I'm a little out of your league, boo boo.
And then like, on the
other side you're like,
Oh I could never be with
you, I'm a little potato.
But I do love to be cuddled.
(both squealing)
♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
♪ Oh, oh oh, oh ♪
♪ Oh, oh, oh, oh, ♪
♪ oh, oh, oh, oh ♪
- We're taking a quiz called
Tick All the Things You Have Said
and We Will Tell You How Single You Are.
- The first one's "Heyyyyy"
with a bunch of y's.
That is like me to a T.
- Yeah, I also say that.
- Heyyyy youuu.
- That's more reserved for like, you know,
you know I've done that.
- Hey with one y is concerning
like there's something wrong.
But a bunch of heys like heyyyy,
like friendly and it's just one word.
It's so little work.
- Shit, too many yyys.
I'd never say that.
That's so,
- Aw, man I have said
- You would say that.
- I always say that, I'm too
busy with work right now.
- I'm just too busy with work right now.
Yup, that's me.
- Yup.
Hello.
- But that's true.
- You do so many things.
- I'm already like uggggh.
- What if I become a crazy cat lady?
I've thought about this
but the thing is I don't
like cats and I'm not a lady
so what is the male equivalent?
I think it's just like
me playing N64 by myself
with a bottle of whiskey.
- "Why is it so hard to find someone?"
Yes, I have said that.
- I'm checking off way more
than I thought I would.
I'm like boom, boom, boom.
- I'm not just going to settle for anyone.
- That's true
- Yeah, I've said that.
- I feel like I am picky.
Like I come home and there
is no significant other
with me for the holidays.
My mom just gave up on me.
She's like, You're just
the pickiest person I know.
- My friends call it the But.
I was telling you like Oh my god, like,
I met this guy.
Didadidadidadie."
And they'll be like Okay,
but where is the but?
And I'm like But...
- No, you are picky.
- See, I am picky.
That one for me is 'cause like,
I feel like I've watched my parents.
My parents have been
together for, like, 30 years.
They went through a lot of ups and downs
and so for me, I'm like,
Oh I'm not willing to put
up with that much bullshit.
Which maybe I should,
'cause they've been together for so long.
- I definitely said,
what should I text back?
cause I'm always
screenshotting my conversations
and sending them to my friends.
- I just want someone to talk to.
- No, I have a dog.
- I don't have a dog.
- I just want someone who makes me laugh.
Yes.
- Yes.
- Dating is so shit.
It is indeed, very shit.
- Where do you meet people these days?
I've never,
- No, I've never said that.
- I'd never say that, 'cause clearly,
- I've tried Tinder.
- Where do you meet people these days?
I feel like it's very difficult,
I feel like everyone's on social media.
I may have dabbled in some DM's.
- I think I'm going to stay in
and maybe watch some Netflix tonight.
Yes
- I've definitely said,
who needs love anyway?
- Me.
I need love.
- I thought being single
was meant to be fun.
- It is fun!
- It is fun.
- Especially if you're in your ho days.
I'm no longer in my ho days,
but when I was in my ho days, oh!
- I've never had a, ho day phase.
- You just need to run
down the rack of dicks,
and just like, hit em all, touch em all.
- Eww!
(giggles)
- Like you're running down the
aisles of a clothing store.
- I don't even care about Valentine's Day.
I don't care about Valentine's Day.
I usually schedule the off-again
between Thanksgiving and February 15th.
- Oh, my God.
So you just tease during the holidays?
- Bear's hibernate.
- I love Valentine's Day.
- Yeah?
- Even when I'm single.
- You do?
- My mom sends me a gift.
- Oh, my God, I'm so lonely.
Yes, I've said that.
- I've never, I've never said that.
Really?
Why didn't you just call me?
Yeah, just call your friends.
- There's other things that I need.
- Oh, you mean, like, I'm so horny.
- I'm so horny.
Check.
- All day.
Every day.
- No, I'd never say that out loud.
- Why are all the good
men slash women taken?
No, they're not.
Clearly.
Woo hoo!
- Here it is.
These are results of how single we were,
when we were single.
- I feel like this is like, a teacher,
giving me a grade on my love life.
- I got 14 out of 49.
That's 28% single.
Back when I was single.
Which, I feel like is pretty accurate.
- I'm 30% single.
It says, you're still
enduring the single life.
- You're at the point
where it's all new and fun.
- Enjoy it.
Oh, this is very me.
You know me so well.
- I don't know if I would
say it was new and fun.
When I was single, I wasn't
stressed about being single.
I kind of just rolled with it,
and let the chips fall where they did.
- That's just such a
beautiful way to live.
I wish everyone could live like Ella.
- I think that just comes with
not having a high sex drive.
- That sure as hell
ain't gonna happen to me.
- Ooooh, 53%!
Mine says, You're still
pretty hopeful, you're dating,
and yes, it could be shit, but
it also could be really good.
The one is just around the corner.
(gasps)
- Where?
- Hello?
It's true, I am still hopeful.
I know somebody just to make
my heart happy is waiting
- Yeah.
- I got 30 out of 49, I am 61% single.
Hmm.
You've been single for way too long.
Okay.
That's an attack on me.
Cool.
Quite frankly, you're sick of this shit.
You're sick of dating.
Sick of trying.
You're just sick of it all.
But it's all good, keep
doing you, and being great.
What?
- That seems right.
You do seem sick of it.
- I am very sick of it, yeah.
Years and years of dating,
you do get sick of this shit.
It's like, life is terrible, have fun!
- Just keep doing you!
- Good luck!
- Listen up, single people!
We are single.
- And we're great.
- If you have such an negative
attitude towards love,
then you are not going to receive.
- To the single audience, I say,
Good luck.
- I think that people need to
look for love in other places,
other than one person.
You need to look for love
through your best friends,
or your family, I think that
you need to also self love.
Or like, even your cat.
You know?
Who the fuck is hitting me up?
Oh, it's Tinder.
- Oh, Tinder!
Wow!
- Stay true to yourself.
Be safe.
Value your needs first.
- If you want to holla at me,
definitely slide into my DMs.
Don't send me anything dirty,
'cause I usually screenshot that
and send it to all my friends.
- We're in a day and
age where it's real fun,
but real sad at the same time.
We are in the era of options.
An era of beautiful filters.
An era of swipes.
So it can seem impossible
that you'll ever find the right one.
It's like a big old buffet,
but usually buffets don't taste that good.
So, take your time.
Wait for the proper meal.
- That's true.
- Oh, oh, yes.
- We're single, you guys.
Really, really single.
- Yeah, we're so single.
(upbeat music)
Oh, yes, wait, move it
around a little bit.
Yes!
(both laughing)